Speaker 1: We're going to keep delving into the
anti trans panic as a result of the shooting in
Nashville, Tennessee. But one of the things that
is front of mind for me and there's a very good
vice news article about this is that the trans
identity of the Nashville, Tennessee shooter,
despite the fact that, what, three or four
out of the last 5000 mass shooters have been
not even necessarily trans either non-binary or
trans like four out of 5000. Okay. Despite that,
all of a sudden. The right wingers are seeing the
trans identity of the Nashville shooter as the
opening to declare a full scale war against the
trans community. I am extraordinarily concerned
about our trans friends and allies because I do
believe that they are at serious risk. It's not
an exaggeration. I think that this is this is an
overt threat we are now seeing for for several
years now. To be perfectly honest, I have pointed
out to you that at events like CPAC and others,
the biggest applause lines, even at Trump
rallies, the biggest applause lines come
during the anti-trans moments of speeches
when Ted Cruz says, My pronouns are kiss
my ass and everybody stands and cheers.
And Trump says, We must not allow teachers
to teach transgender without parental consult
consent. And the crowd cheers and they go crazy.
This has been building for a while and it's now
open season. Vice News Writing The Right is using
the Nashville shooting to declare war on trans
people. It has been an online barrage towards
basically any visible trans person online. Tucker
Carlson did a segment in which he claims that the
trans community is actually targeting Christians.
We're going to talk about that separately. I don't
even want to delve into that now because it really
deserves its own segment. But as the article says,
as soon as details started to emerge about the
shooter in Nashville, pundits and politicians
on the right started exploiting the tragedy to
spread anti-trans hate. You know, almost every
mass shooter is a young white male. Not all of
them, but most of them. You look at the last 5000
mass shootings, like I said, it's overwhelmingly
young white men. And so when that is the case,
all of a sudden many of these right wing networks
and people have nothing to say. They have nothing
to say now. To a certain extent, when they're Kyle
Collins, he said this yesterday in a great video,
which I'll talk about later that he did about
my controversy related to the shooting. He said,
you know, these shootings are so common that
like when three people are killed in a shooting.
We all say, Do we talk about is this a story?
Because there's like three of these a day in
the United States? Is this a story? And for many
of these right wingers, when it is the what we
call it, imagine we have like our traditional
mass shooting in the U.S., young white male
gets an AR 15, maybe also a handgun and goes crazy
and starts shooting people either because of.
We've seen every we've seen everything disgruntled
employment, employment stuff targeting a
particular race. We've seen all of it. We've seen
all of it. Is it even a story? And it isn't always
a story. And a lot of the right wingers don't
even comment. All of a sudden the trans identity
of this individual is exposed and reported on and
every right winger wants to talk about it. This is
the important mass shooting to talk about. Never
mind that there have been I mean, if we want to
be precise, what is the let's see, how many mass
shootings have there already been since this one?
Oh, I don't have an updated list.
Okay. Oh, wait. Last 72 hours.
So let's see. One, two. There's been a bunch of
mass shootings since this one. But they want to
talk about the one with the trans shooter. And
the most important takeaways, of course, are
that these are people who don't actually want to
do anything about guns. Their priority, if they do
talk about a shooting or if they don't talk about
a shooting, it's to serve their primary purpose,
which is don't deal with guns. Don't look at
implementing any of the ten ideas that I presented
to you yesterday, one trans person versus how
many non trans mass shooters. So transgenderism
must be the problem. Drag shows which don't have
anything to do with it must be the problem. All of
them have guns, but the guns aren't the problem.
Oh, but mental illness is the problem. But we
don't want to commit any money to treating mental
illness. But now that the shooter is trans, then
we must spread transphobia. We must spread anti
LGBT sentiment in general. And it's disturbing
and it's depressing. Marjorie Taylor GREENE
particularly disgusting. She is calling for trans
vengeance. She has been suspended from Twitter and
we will talk about that separately again, because
I believe it's its own form of evil, which we will
discuss. And of course, then we always go back to
when people like me say, hey, I've had a proposal
with ten different provisions to deal with some
of the gun aspects of this. I've had the
proposal for four years. David It's too soon
to politicize the tragedy. We must not make it
political, really, when we actually want to look
at solutions to the problem. It's too soon. But
it is never too soon to spread hate and to say,
well, drag time story hour is what caused this.
What? And I don't even want to go into this yet
because there's a lot of allegations flying
around. But what really may be at issue here,
what really may be at issue here, is the treatment
of the individual and who ultimately did this at
that school. And we're still learning more about
that. And hopefully at some point we will know
the full story. But it is open season on the trans
community. We all need to be extremely concerned
about this and we're going to continue talking
about it more. Make sure you subscribe to the
YouTube channel YouTube.com slash The David Pakman
Show. So much coming up on the program today